il ne restait plus qu elle ou presque or
son ville prenez en libye nous encore
adobe ils sont aujourd'hui fibre et
elles font partie des toutes dernières
communes reliées au très haut débit
paris ville fibre on est ravis sur horse
en ville parce que metz a changé notre
vie pour les habitants et pour les
entreprises pour les mairies c'est hyper
important parce que depuis longtemps
nous demande la dématérialisation et
quand on était en adsl c'était pas
terrible terrible et maintenant bas
c'est le jour et la nuit 1 pour
l'instant j'ai que de l'adsl et
c'est pas terrible terrible quoi je
pense que c'est indispensable
et puis moi je fais du télétravail donc
c'est important d'avoir quelque chose
qui va quitter rapide la fibre moyens
importance je fais beaucoup de
télétravail je suis blessée qu'elle
arrive pour pouvoir travailler dans de
meilleures conditions au jour
d'aujourd'hui avec ces derniers
chantiers plus de 96 % du réseau yvin
fibre est désormais éligible une réunion
publique était organisée à paris doivent
ils c'est une vraie fierté parce que
c'était pas évident c'est une vraie
fierté parce qu'on est l'un des premiers
départements 100% fibres et sur les
zones rurales et ça c'est quelque chose
qui est important et c'est aussi porteur
d'avenir puisque on a un petit peu
anticiper les mutations les mouvements
avec le co vide on a vu que beaucoup de
nos compatriotes souhaitait quitter un
petit peu là la ville pour aller à la
campagne il soit sauvegardée
effectivement cette proximité avec les
entreprises des câbles étaient encore
tiré il y à peu comme en ce début de
mois de mars les équipes sont sur le
terrain objectif du jour raccorder amoa
orso ville grâce à plusieurs mètres de
câbles sous terre et en hauteur
c'est un énorme travail puisque ont
attiré 6000 kilomètres de fibre on a
fait plus de 200 km2 de trancher on a
fait plus de 1000 chantiers pour réparer
des fourreaux pour changer les poteaux
donc c'est un travail énorme qui demande
énormément de
de moyens humains et puis des temps
machine également extrêmement important
et si je prends le cas de alain ville et
de paris doivent ils ça fait huit mois
neuf moins que les équipes travaillent
pour aller chercher ces deux communes
la totalité des communes de rambouillet
territoire est aujourd'hui éligibles
parmi les prochains projets de seine et
yvelines numériques le déploiement des
tablettes dans tous les collèges du
département